est ce que vous êtes content d'être au
canada
la famille est enfin réunie
genre 10 est allé chercher sa femme et
ses enfants à la frontière jeudi
et qui a la passion
arrivé à montréal en 2017 il n'avait
encore jamais rencontré sa fille c'était
époustouflant
parce que la petite coralie et et elle
m'a sauté dessus quand j'étais malade et
dans la g elle va poser la question est
ce que ces trois audi
sa femme et lui s'étaient séparés alors
qu'elle était enceinte il ya près de
cinq ans il dit avoir échappé un
kidnapping en haïti
esther n'avait pas de visa comme genre
audi elle a trouvé refuge au chili nous
lui avions parlé la semaine dernière
après avoir traversé le continent pour
rejoindre son mari elle était aux états
unis
elle s'est d'abord présenté au poste de
la colle mais on lui a refusé l'entrée
au canada et n'a eu d'autre choix que
d'emprunter le chemin loxam le chemin
est rouvert depuis près de trois
semaines déjà des centaines de personnes
sont passées par là et surtout les
jeunes qui sont bien habillés c'est pas
tous les gens qui sont au fait de
commentaire
le bloc québécois a remis une lettre au
ministre de l'immigration pour lui
demander d'intervenir en faveur des
stères il pourrait y avoir eu erreur
quand elle a été refoulée la première
fois elle venait après tout rejoindre
membres de la famille ce refus fait en
sorte aujourd'hui que son statut est
incertain elle va être demandeur d'asile
elle aura
permis travail
afin de rester ici elle fera une demande
de résidence permanente pour des motifs
humanitaires
voilà j'ai danse permanente et est
retourné aux études et donnés en aux
tours qu'est ce que la société m'a donné
la famille encore un long chemin à
parcourir un cas qui illustrent à quel
point la réunification familiale peut
être compliqué j'aurais aimé que que ce
serait que le gouvernement
facilite ma famille
et peu importe la couleur
mais ces avances un pas à la fois et
profite de chaque instant ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada morin